welcome everybody I hope you're enjoying
the carnival events today's session is
in celebration of ionized 20 year
anniversary the ini or the information
networking Institute is a department in
the College of Engineering that offers
professional graduate degree programs in
networking information security mobility
and software management in pittsburgh in
silicon valley through bicoastal
programs the combined time here in
Pittsburgh and Silicon Valley and
international programs in athens greece
kobe japan and lisbon and a vero
portugal we're very fortunate that we
have a great group of panelists here
today and leading this panel moderating
this panel is the Dean of the College of
Engineering Pradeep Khosla who was also
formerly a one of the directors of I and
I and he is the founder of Carnegie
Mellon scilab which is an
interdisciplinary initiative involving
more than 200 faculty staff and students
from across the university solving
problems related to secure available to
trustworthy communication systems and I
probably left one of the adjectives out
but that's okay i will introduce pretty
briefly hits other positions prior to
being Dean of the College of Engineering
he was head of the Department of
Electrical and Computer Engineering
founder and director of the Institute
for complex engineered systems or
otherwise known as Isis the program
manager for DARPA where he managed a 50
million portfolio of programs in real
time systems internet-enabled software
infrastructure intelligence systems and
distributed systems and as I mentioned
before he was director of I and I so I'm
going to hand it over to you Pradeep
Thank You Dina good afternoon everybody
I'm glad she stopped otherwise that
would be the panel
reading somebody's resume which is Iran
so we have a great set of panelists here
today and the question in front of the
panel is security and privacy is there a
trade off if any and how can we get both
together seems to me going in this is
like proving p equals NP so I don't know
how many of you know what the problem is
but it's one of those problems which is
like the holy grail of computer
scientists we're still trying to work on
it but it's sort of meat Hawking the
goal today for the next hour is for my
colleagues out here to talk so what I'm
going to do is give 30 seconds to each
one of them to tell them to tell you
their name and their number as I'm not
there I thought the Social Security
numbers are better identifier than the
name but alessandra would disagree with
me and name and their name and their
affiliation and then after that each one
would get about two to three minutes to
talk about the issue at hand and then
we'll follow that up with a question and
answers initially from me and then open
it up to the audience that good so let
me start with right to my left here
Alexandra Alexandra Christy and my date
of birth is I mean I'm an economist by
training I'm interest in the economics
of privacy which is a study of the
trade-offs associated with protecting a
revealing data but more and more in the
last year CMU given the great
interaction i could have with security
people and psychology is in behavioral
decisional researcher i got interesting
what i call the behavioral economics or
privacy which is understanding of people
as well as organizations make decisions
about their data they are privacy their
security and how those decisions can be
biased in the cognitive and behavioral
sense and maybe later in the planet we
will get to explain what they're really
means hey drew my name is Adrian Pyrrhic
I'm a faculty here in ECE EPP and
computers
teach several of the i nine classes
seeing some familiar faces students have
suffered in my classes I guess but I
hope in retrospect you all enjoyed it
and made you stronger and better so I
teach one of the network security
classes and the trade-off between
security and privacy is important
challenging that in that environment of
for securing networks and I'll talk a
bit more about that later Laurie hi I'm
Laurie Craner and I'm a faculty member
here in engineering and public policy
and in computer science and I direct a
lab that's part of Scilab is called the
Scilab usable privacy and security
laboratory so my research is focused on
human factors related to security and
privacy and when people hear that I do
usable privacy and security and they say
well isn't that an oxymoron King can you
really do all those things together or
even any two of them and i hope i hope
the answer is that yes we can find ways
of doing these things together Roman hi
I'm Roman Jenna do I'm the technical
director of the cyber threat and
vulnerability analysis at the software
engineering Institute that's a federal
lab here and if you take it with the
humor intended I guess my core business
is anti privacy we're building tagging
to make sure that from the perspective
of the US government we can understand
as much as we possibly can we're here to
help of course oh and of course most
important time in ms 11-man my name is
Matt car I'm a ms69 graduated in 2006 or
the security degree after I did that I
went to go work for The MITRE
corporation and I'm currently a infosec
engineer with them and I help my job as
I help the government field cross-domain
solutions and why does it mean all that
anybody in the crowd but their systems
that connect unclassified networks with
classified networks and help for
information sharing the kind of like a
mission impossible where the guy went
into the room it was the clean room and
you couldn't nobody else could go in
there that's not really real life
we have computers that have connections
both to the classified side and the
unclassified side and so from a private
privacy perspective I guess I'm focused
on you know how we can help that sharing
to be done in a more responsible way
thank you so let me start with as you
see we have an eclectic combination of
people who do security people who do
privacy people for privacy people
against privacy or at least one of them
and so what I want to do is I want to
start with this whole notion of
information sharing which i think is a
fundamental notion whether it is
security or privacy because in some
sense when you give giant eagle your
information you're sharing your
information with giant eagle now people
might disagree with me they might think
it's private information so let me start
with Matt because he works a lot with
Department of Defense and I want to
understand on when you fight a war and a
multinational force is on the ground
with different set of systems talk a
little bit about information sharing and
who decides who gets what and what is
good to tell who certainly so you know
this is from my kind of seat in McLean
Virginia and I'm a very far you know
very far away from the battlefield and
and I should say that all of my opinions
are my own and do not represent my
employer that they actually tell you
actually tell us to save them but uh but
I do think that there is a delicate
balance because the u.s. from what I've
seen is they're very very comfortable
with going to war where they control
both the battle space and all the
information that's exchanged in that
battle space and they fight the wars on
networks that they completely control
and own but when it comes to coalition
operations typically the networks then
become jointly owned and jointly
maintained so all of the countries that
are participating all have a say in and
what gets put on them the systems that
get to put in them the information
that's traded across them you know when
it comes to firing a missile to
deploying
more equipment for the troops this type
of things then take on a joint
atmosphere as opposed to just being us
us-led so all of our our systems that
that aim to interoperate our
interconnect these networks you know the
different classified networks there's
all kinds of different classifications
and range from really high stuff that
the Intel community uses two more of the
mid-level classifications that there the
war is fought on there are it is it is
very difficult i'm trying to get to an
answer here but i don't know if i'll do
it the next couple of seconds but you
you want to know what was the given what
i just said see it seems like you have
not changed you know when you're a
professor you talk for 40 minutes and
the student says what did you say no i
think you nearly address the point which
was trying to give people an impression
of an idea of the challenge is
associated with multinational forces on
the ground and the lack of interoperable
systems and how do you overcome that yet
yes so the the systems interoperate to a
certain extent I mean we all speak the
same protocols it's not like systems
that they that they use in in France or
in trying to think of other coalition
partners oh well our Afghan mission
partners don't speak the same protocols
but when it comes to the rules by which
you get to exchange the data that's
where it gets very very hairy I mean you
take the the whole a group of Nations
that combine to form our coalition in
Afghanistan and we have better
relationships with some of those nations
than others and so when it comes to
sharing mission data there are caveats
to how much we can share and and some
stuff you know some stuff doesn't go
beyond the US borders and those borders
extend to our networks too so it's not
just the Geographic borders we we
maintain our own networks we operate
them and we can't we don't share beyond
them certain types of critical data
that's sensitive
but there is a the u.s. is working very
hard and the meetings I've been in they
are emphasizing the need to open up more
of that data to more people that are
helping us to fight the war and that's
the I think that is one of the big
battles right now that's good so that
sets the stage for the question for
Roman where I want them to tell us what
are the threats to our privacy that the
US government what is the information US
government is looking at on all
individuals no so I'm okay keep going i
was going to back up an add a little bit
but you kind of exactly that each i
think what's changing the US government
in the last couple years is a real
appreciation for you know the cliche
right the interconnectedness of it all
we kind of envisioned in the media you
know these big operation centers where
you guys are seeing at keyboards having
situational awareness you see the you a
UAV video kind of been one big screen
and your fancy charts in another you
know flag officers kind of walking
around making sure everything works yeah
that's true kind of mostly it's smoke
and mirrors anyway right to justify the
existence of that big center there is
kind of a real appreciation for the need
to share information even if it's
sometimes kind of one way with what's
happening industry in all those places
in addition to you know thinking about
what's happening in theater they're also
sucking in a lot of information that
everyone else is doing in the commercial
space trying to understand what is this
situational awareness in the internet a
lot of DoD systems are very much
interconnected with things on the
internet they're not kind of an island
and we talk about a lot of
classification data but think about all
the defense contractors in which dvds
doing business with payroll inventory
how you by screws you know hammers and
so there is a there is a lot of interest
in understanding kind of big picture
what's happening on the internet and
kind of reflecting that back in the
government and there's a lot of
instances where there's a recognition
that you need to give information back
to private sector based on big picture
insights that the government's made I
think there's been you know it's
certainly some advances ensuring that
class of information
you know back to back to the private
sector let me switch to Adrienne because
he's the other security guy sir Adrian
computer science there's a great concept
called zero knowledge proofs where I can
prove to you something without
transmitting any knowledge which is the
whole idea of a lecture that our
professor gear where I can prove to you
I know without telling you what is it
that I know given that and that you're a
specialist and a leader in networking
what do you think is the technology
going forward which would allow us to
have networks that are secure at the
same time hide the private information
from unwanted people right that's a very
interesting challenge to design networks
that don't disclose information about
people without for people at domus
behaves essentially here's what you'd
like to do the network could collect
information but that remains secret as
long as people don't misbehave for
example if somebody does perform an
attack then suddenly there's enough
information that is available that they
the attacker loses the privacy so that
some of the concepts that we're studying
to look at how can we design these
networks in a way that in a common case
or private but in some cases when
someone misbehave so you can actually
exactly figure out who did it and what
they did and essentially through the
attack they uncovered your own privacy
well that's good that part of the work
that's it that you guys are doing in
your group right so for example there's
also future car networks and it's
conceivably in a few years your vehicles
all communicate to each other when you
drive down the highway and there's a lot
of privacy issues in this space as well
to Gareth car manufacturers were right
now looking at how to design systems
that preserve drivers privacy but in
cases are so many means behaves it's
still need to trace people who are
misbehaving and have that ability to two
traits that leads me to lorina because
one can design these complex systems but
clearly they're going to they're going
to be as useful as a human being or his
or her ability to use them so say a
little bit about how do we make these
systems usable because
I think I'm an expert in computers but I
hate looking at these stupid privacy
notices when I log into a website i have
no idea what I'm signing up for yeah so
that's the challenge is to make it
secure in private and and usable and I
think until recently there hadn't been a
whole lot of work in that direction for
the most part you know security people
when they when they did their threat
modeling you know they were they were
basically looking at the you know the
evil the evil e vino and then what that
was a threat to the system and not
really paying attention to the the
normal users of the system and the kind
of threat they pose because they can't
figure out how to use it properly and
that actually poses a big threat and so
in our work we've been looking at how do
we take into account the abilities of
the of the normal users and their
interests and their motivations and the
fact that they don't really want to have
to spend a lot of time doing security
they don't feel like it's their job and
you know you can put up all the posters
in the workplace that security is
everyone's job but most people say hey
it's not really my job you know someone
else to do that so we've been we've been
looking at how how do we come up with
models so that we can take all of that
into account and also try to counter
some of the mythology of security that
there's a lot of things that we do
because we just well everybody knows
right you do that and it turns out that
it's actually not increasing our
security a whole lot but it is making
things really inconvenient so for
example one that you probably all can
relate to is passwords recently CMU for
the andrew network they made everybody
change their password and they said that
we now all have to have a capital letter
or a lowercase letter a symbol and a
number in our password and in theory
that's to make it more secure but it's
not really clear that that actually
makes passwords more secure and we're
it's actually inspired my students to
kind of spontaneously start a research
project looking at how you can maximize
password entropy while minimizing the
pain
into the to the users and surprisingly
they're actually hasn't been very much
research in that area and so that's
something that we're looking at got a
little to add on that actually so just
take one example there's a there was one
of these cross domain solutions that we
were we were looking to deploy and we
were trying to get a sense of how how
much it would take to to administer it
and it turns out they had one already
pulling another location and i'll be
staying here on purpose but one specific
thing i can tell you is that the system
connected a number of networks together
into one into one box all these
different cables running into it and
they said when they were designed the
system that you had to have certain pki
thing's certain certificates all these
passwords it turned out once they
finally deployed it that they were what
was it like 216 passwords to enter into
the system when you start it up and it
took the Appian there were a couple of
different people required to be there
you know to start it up and it would
take over an hour to start at the system
from a cold state so you know you can
imagine that the people that were busy
implementing the security requirements
for this particular system had no idea
that this would be the result of what
they were what they were designing but
you know this just kind of a lack of
usability you know analysis that was
going on there and I thought when I
heard those numbers I just couldn't
believe it that's actually amazing so
let me go to alessandro it seems to me
that money can be a great motivator to
change human behavior in fact there's a
great quote attributable to Winston
Churchill which I will not repeat in
this polite company which talked about
how money can be the motivator so you as
an economist tell us something about how
can we demotivate the government from
collecting too much information and how
can we motivate the individual from
giving up or giving out too much
information well I I will start with a
with a challenge to the very premise
that privacy and security are orthogonal
concepts that we need less or want with
more of the other because of seeing
things from a economics angle the
individual level privacy
is a way to achieve a personal security
I see privacy and security as a trade
offs you Revere lots of pricing
information that the probation could be
used against you for instance for price
discrimination for blackmailing and
therefore protecting your data is a way
to protect your persona and you have
privacy and security at the same time at
the collective level sometimes the
argument is made that well maybe you
need privacy to protect yourself well we
need less privacy to protect the nation
to put that all of us we need to monitor
what evildoers are and because we don't
know who they are way to monitor
everybody so that everybody loses on
privacy but everybody gains in security
I would shatter that as well on two
grounds the first ground is that
accumulating massive amounts of data
creates itself ug security problems and
now him and again we seem dead both
corporations and the government sadly
cannot be trusted with maintaining the
protection of our data so we create
these one point of failures which
creates new security problems by visual
acuity so much data in the second angle
is that in reality we already have
tremendous technologies to achieve
privacy and security at the same time
and this is what also Adrian was
referring to a few minutes ago for the
more technologically oriented in this
room which is pretty much the majority
of you let me quote homomorphic
encryption or lying signature oma
morphic encryption our protocol
encryption crop cryptographic protocols
used for instance in electronic voting
they ensure privacy provable privacy of
voting and also probable verifiability
and security of voting way better the
current really really bad system using
electronic voting I don't even remember
the name of the company producing this
the electronic voting machine which now
again being shown to be to default with
daibo thank you well we have much better
than that cryptographers like Adrian and
others in other universities work on
protocols which are probably secure so
the challenge is how we make the work in
market in licensure developing the 80s
they which almost effing brands and
use for instance in anonymous payments
they allow for payments to be anonymous
but they also allow as Adrienne was
referring to in case somebody tries to
double spend well that person privacy is
revoked by the protocol so we do have
technologies for privacy and security
the challenge is how to make the work in
the marketplace and this is in a way
going back to the initial part of your
question which is a true challenge
because often as individuals as well as
level corporations we focus on the media
concert benefits and we don't think
about the long-term costs and benefits
we think that change the electric sister
and electoral system to use these voting
technologies may be very costly which
can be true in the short run but the
benefits are huge in the long run so the
issue is can we take heat the short term
costs if there is a longer and benefit
to to achieve and sometimes we have too
much a myopic view things and we decide
to keep things as they are keep the
status quo even if it's an either
private non-secure thanks Alexander one
of the things you forgot to mention is
Laurie works on technologies where the
laconic voting machine will not have the
problem of hanging chads because
everybody would know how to use them
properly right Laurie good what I'm
going to do is I'm going to look at you
to ask questions and if I don't see any
hands then I'm just going to keep on
asking questions from my side okay
people are telling me to shut up now
perfect so you are one you are too tight
so before anybody answers instruction to
my panelists don't feel obligated to
answer everybody should not feel
obligated to answer every question
because otherwise we'll only be answered
one question so go ahead whoever feels
most comfortable who wants to take that
if you don't take it I'll assign it I
guess take this one actually a natural
allottee one of the maybe I should
explain the late what what what is means
for for most people in a non zero
knowledge this way hopefully so in a
nutshell it's about is peace ability to
or ISPs are trying to shape the traffic
in a way that an SC Marvin service here
is actually maybe he should answer this
question really because he is the expert
in this in this field but essentially
it's about is peace that are shaping the
traffic to their advantage so for
example comcast would try to prevent
skype from all routes downgrade skype
traffic itself in order to provide a
better service for their own for their
own phone offering and so in essence
security helps in circumventing such
shaping so for example if file sharing
would if one is P would want to limit
voucher and you could disguise file
sharing traffic as legitimate or other
traffic that's not being throttled by
the ISP so you can make one traffic look
like another now of course it is often
times a cat and mouse game where
security is being used to hide traffic
and make it look like some other traffic
but then the ISP noticing this can try
to counteract this so one example is you
could and that's a very old example
people make web traffic look like the NS
Creek
and that of course becomes very quickly
obvious if you if you're looking for if
you don't look for repentance it goes
underneath the radar but that's been
some of the ways in which people try to
circumvent such such filtering anybody
else wanna make a comment otherwise we
have number two waiting I'll go for
maybe Marvin Marvin you wanna sure not
sure actually answer to question but
there was Part B to that question where
we'll get to that it was about court of
appeals or court of law or something
right so I mean net neutrality it's a
very difficult topic that we could have
a whole panel on maybe go for
imported of course basically tells that
under
Lauren
a girlfriend alumni the question I have
nobody what we are discovering about
privacy on the threats exposed to our
formation are we thinking about security
and how we secure our information in the
right way or consider some of these
concepts
do I see a hand Roman did you raise your
hand thank you how diplomatic well I was
just so the one thing that actually
comes to mind when you asked that
question is something that just occurred
you know cloud computing came up in the
last panel and so where are you keeping
your information I mean the mantra of
the cloud is right it's not yours
anymore and so what just happened is the
name of the name escapes me but in the
last two days there was the rest of a
rest of a pretty significant spammer and
what they found is you know most of the
evidence that have on him is because he
kept it in google docs in the cloud so
we had an interesting kind of paradigm
shift from law enforcement kind of so to
speak so instead of tracking down the
guy breaking you know kind of getting
getting the right Warren coming to his
house season his computer doing all
those things all they had to do was
serve something to Google who very
efficiently said yes this is a legal war
happy to give you this information
without even actually notifying you know
whose data it is and so kind of from
from a law enforcement perspective you
know this is actually quite fantastic
ISPs are very much geared for Kalia and
a lot of other statute to provide
information on others and so it's kind
of an example of their data is your data
easier to get you because you just
physically don't control them so yeah
you certainly have to think about that
you know we talked about kind of giant
eagle genuine car it's one of the kind
of the big Bugaboo is that that is kind
of what happens when you know giant
eagle fails right your data that you
willingly gave them you know can be
auctioned off and kind of sold no soul
to others you know the example it's
commonly cited from the grocery store
model was you know I buy a lot of beer
someone might notice of course not in
Pennsylvania that I'm buying beer you
know perhaps CEO every other day through
that credit card transaction you know
wouldn't a lot of health care folks like
to know that you know I'm buying this
much or red meat or kind of whatever
whatever it might be so back to your
kind of a lot of stuff is getting
collect you're just kind of you
appreciate what I'm anybody else will
know that too then well you guys are
thinking about a question let me pose a
question which is similar to net
neutrality but I think of equal value
and maybe of different type of
importance and that is anonymity on the
network there is a big crowd of people
you know really I don't
right-wing or left-wing but one of those
wings that actually strongly believe in
anonymity on the network and I want to
pose to our panel I haven't been able to
figure out why should there be any
anonymity on the network how does it
impact privacy how does it impact
security if you don't raise your hand I
will Lori see you seem like you're ready
all right why should there be anonymity
um so I I think in in general most
people feel like what they do is just
not other people's business and as long
as we have a network where everything is
trapped great you can't really make your
business not other people's business and
and I think we need to have an enema d
so that we can all just you know be
alone and not be bothered and and I I
agree that there there is a tension and
that if everybody was anonymous and even
the bad guys are anonymous too and it
becomes more difficult to track them
down but I I think most of us don't want
to live in a world where you know big
brother is watching us all the time and
so we we need to have these mechanisms
to allow us to to not have everybody
following us around and watching
everything that we do and have
everything that that we've say or all
our transactions be tracked and archived
forever Alexandra he has an economic
model okay so actually i was about to
pretend to be a lost color and go back
to the American Constitution say rather
than rather than pretended to be an
economist so there are good there are
good reasons why we need unlimited why
anonymity can be positive for the
individual for the society and one
example is going back to the
constitution amendments of the
Constitution is a is a way to a free
speech there would be a chilling
effective everything you say should
always be identified and connect
view there is a longer jurisprudence in
this area and it is true people feel
freer to express even undesirable and no
popular opinions when the privacy in the
form anonymity is protected at the same
time there are reasons why when we don't
have anonymity and we not have privacy
we we suffer from that several
psychological studies have shown that
the feeling of being being constantly
under surveillance under monitoring is
truly detrimental to the psychology on
the individual there are significant
long-term costs and the we human beings
if you see the literature on privacy
anonymity topological studies going back
trying to establish what was the sense
of privacy in the ancient Rome or
ancient Greece or in different countries
it's through the different countries are
different and so privacy but you can
find a need for privacy in all countries
all times it takes different forms but
you can always find it because it's an
eight-part psychological need of the
individual if he lacks if you take it
away the consequence k be negative so
anonymity as psychological protection
that's it's another is why we need it
whether we have it that's another issue
because studies that Laurie has been
doing Brad Moline who I see sitting
there in the audience has been doing
myself on a really difficult
demonization show that it's become
virtually impossible to remain private
there is so much data out there in the
video piece of information personal but
maybe not uniquely identifiable which
one's connected for data mining can
truly be identified individual so
effectively we are losing anonymity um
but that doesn't mean that we don't need
it any longer it's it's interesting now
you take and I'm just thinking too like
web surfing completely not related to my
job but if you if you're comparing
online services where your identity is
tightly bound to your account that you
establish with the service versus ones
that aren't it tends to it it influences
behavior at least from what I've seen
like if you go on facebook people are
tender tend to be civil you know you
tend to you know
you don't see a lot of spam a lot of
comments it unless you know it's viruses
or something but you if you go on
youtube and you read the comments for
the average video on youtube that it's
it's kind of disgusting to read a lot of
that stuff that's on there and people
the accounts that people create our it's
much more difficult to track those back
to a person without the help of law
enforcement and they're not breaking the
law they're just they're just being you
know who they want to be and they are
kind of shrouded in this with the
account that they have they think it's
difficult to find out who it really is I
talked about that they're gonna be
matching since we're talking about web
browsing so we're talking about kind of
who's big brother you know is that who
is that right i mean let's take an
example of google it all comes down to
convenience right a lot of people in
this room probably have gmail accounts
how many of you log out of your gmail
gmail account clear the clear your
cookies before you type something you
know to actually google in a search for
something you go a lot of people just
kind of don't care and allow that day to
accumulate because it's a convenience
well I wouldn't say they don't care I'd
say that people do care but it's really
inconvenient and so there there's kind
of a trade-off between you know am I
willing to spend that amount of timing
the cost of privacy is actually very
expensive well that in there you know
there is some val is gonna tell you that
there's some value to them collecting
your searches over time they could then
offer you more customized search result
they have figured out how to monetize it
for themselves but then the stock value
goes up and then we make money
alessandra you want to do or just go
ahead it was just one more issues also
that has changed a lot is sheer
simplicity which you can gather data
these days of course a lot of data is
available digitally but again in the
context of a chlorotic networks that
which is a very active area that car
companies are working on these days
there's an interesting challenge which
is if vehicles broadcast their identity
ten times a second are we losing a lot
of privacy and one of the interesting
counter-argument is well a vehicle it's
already of license plates that are
already uniquely identify your car
but then you know why would we really
care about these wireless messages being
sent well it's actually the simplicity
at which you can really follow people if
you need to set up cameras all along the
way and then you need to identify
license plate that's not that easy and
it's not as reliable however if vehicles
broadcast wirelessly their identity 10
times a second it becomes very easy for
everyone to track everyone else and so
these new technologies really have a
huge impact then we need to be very
careful how we how we provide and retain
anonymity privacy in such environments
but they're already doing that aren't
they with the with the traffic you pop a
traffic view on google maps and they
they are aggregating so what they're
doing is right based in cell phone so
you could say well people contract cell
phones but they're the argument is with
cell phones you have a shin to opt out
of it okay you don't need to have a cell
phone but if you have a car you would
have to have this built-in you can
turning off your cell phone turns out
not to be sufficient not to be tracking
seeing actually after we remove the
battery but you have that option to
remove the battery out of your cell
phone but that's the issue in cars you
can't do you really think that there's
in today's day and age not having a cell
phone is any more of a choice than not
having a car i would actually sooner
give up my car than myself well is there
an f that choice as well however again
in the in the cell phone you know you
can remain anonymous by removing or at
least you can't be traced when you walk
around if you remove the battery tesco
top take a bus but you can still get
handed over alessandra and then question
number three and question number four so
go for it just to be comment i thought
that Matt was made of very true an
important point in terms of hinting at
the potential antisocial behavior that
anonymity can bring online and there is
definitely undeniably some empirical
evidence for that among economies there
is a famous paper by polarize Nick
called the social cost of chip settings
showing the ship sailing so easy
anonymity
can decrease the overall welfare of a
certain system however interestingly
there is also evidence for the contrary
studies by Ted pulse name with a
sociologist who social psychologists
sorry it's shown how anonymity can
increase collaboration in a team and it
argues that there is a that's why that's
because by collaborating anonymously
online the the sense of the ego the
sense of contributed to your ego
decreases in the value of contributing
to the group increases so my point being
there is evidence that it could lead to
antisocial behavior there's also
evidence for for the opposite day is
usually research in real life the devil
is in the details I think collaborating
and anonymously also has advantages to
the students you will never get caught
or even if you get caught the other
parties would not be culpable anymore
anyway question number three
if you're being one what should I be
most concerned about
here
because it sounds like
it's
so which one of those
alessandra you want to take that or Lori
well okay yeah if i were to answer the
question for myself i would take an
economist approach which is marginal
cost marginal benefit which is what is
the additional cost it would take me to
protect a certain type of information my
financial information my favorite
information my my personal sexual or
health information and then the marginal
costs of not protecting if I suffer from
a very contagious disease maybe it's
very important for me to protect health
information if I'm saying like L feel
like a fish probably i don't need to
spend in fact i don't want to spend a
lot in protecting my privacy in fact i
want everybody to know right so it
really depends on your personal cost do
you pass out costs and benefits to what
information about you can cause you more
damage and what formation about you if
traded can bring you more benefit so i
don't quite understand that because it
is not that there's money to be made for
example there's money to be made by
giving out information in fact not
giving giant eagle my information cost
me ten percent every time i go shop them
right so but so i'm trying to understand
what is a choice out here
patches haha look well so so i think
that there's there's some aspects of
privacy that can have direct financial
impact so for example if if information
about you getting revealed cost you a
job right that that costs you money the
fact that that information you didn't
want to get out got out or if it causes
you not to get health insurance you know
that that costs you money but then
there's also a lot of intangibles of
just you know certain information got
out and now I'm embarrassed well it
didn't cost me money directly but but it
has value to me and you have to figure
out how to pet a put a price on that and
you know with john eagle yeah you know
so is you ten dollars a week or whatever
ten percent of your grocery bills is way
that versus okay well what is what is
the risk if giant eagle has can track
everything that i eat and they might
sell it to who knows and you can make
that personal calculation you want to
follow it
how is she
because in some cases organization like
tears
they drive when they can be and CE but
then and so that's something with
several you don't fail me but there are
other cases
where if a lot of life is shown on them
they could have been
who wants to take that seems like it's
politically charged go ahead Alexandra
just probably been of the satisfactory
answer in fatty is not a direct answer
just a mention of maybe a resource to
look more after which is a justice
Brandis Warren Brandis were the two
authors of the seminal work on privacy
that we all some of you in this room
took my class my privacy class and it's
a discussing every privacy class in this
country the right of privacy our glory
view 1890 or 80 90 180 9380 natick
Warren Brandis at the time were too
young upcoming Boston lawyers who
discuss the need for privacy as a
protection for invasion in your private
space around 30 years later Brandi's
became a Supreme Court justice and in
world a new work on the need for
transparency in the government Brandis
it was a strong believer individual
privacy and transparency of corporations
and the government I share his views and
but i would recommend the Buffy's his
manuscripts as a young lawyer and then
as the Supreme Court of Justice as
because they are truly enlightening
documents now let's go to question
number four and then I want to come back
to this year 54
so the question in case you don't hear
it is what do you think is the next
generation protocols for security and
privacy research right for medical right
for medical research Adrienne ok no what
is wrestling so well some of the
difficulties in the medical spaces and
the distinction between the need to know
and the you know not needing to know so
for example recently there's been some
audits of some hospitals where medical
information was being accessed of some
celebrities that were delivered in
hospitals and immediately they're a
bunch of accesses by doctors and nurses
and other staff and only one of those
these accesses was legitimate so what
was interesting is through the access
logs you could exactly tell who made the
accesses and then later on you could
determine which accesses were legitimate
and which ones weren't so the the staff
that made the illegitimate accesses they
then I will face with with with some
detentions so essentially looking at
this as an example gives us a way to
deal with these issues in the future as
well so such tracing for example it can
help you in providing a deterrent for
illegitimate accesses so just to take a
concrete example it's in future homes
you have a door lock that can be opened
by any medical staff if you have if they
have reason to believe that there was
some emergency so for example you face a
heart attack or somebody dialed 911 they
can actually come and open your door
lock in the home and later on if if
there's been an illegitimate intrusion
you could later go back and say well
it's this person who open it and the
access was illegitimate so that's one of
the promising directions to go in but of
course there's a lot of privacy and
issues that come up in this context if
you log a lot of these accesses but
again
deterrence can be a very powerful force
against such access is especially in the
medical field and I think there that's
one of the best ways for handling
privacy medical areas i believe so let
me understand that so i think the
question was what are the next
generation protocols and i think so i
read that as technical protocols like
TCP IP or standards like HTML but I
think what you're suggesting is that
infrastructure is going to pretty much
remain the same and there have to be a
layer of protocols above that which are
behavioral policy-oriented protocols
that will decide who has access to what
information how often and so on and so
forth or essentially have equipped these
protocols with logging mechanisms that
then later on if there wasn't a
legitimate access to determine who who
made this access thing Roman is not
excited I mean what would think that we
actually have all that I mean what we
didn't come to my consensus is what's
the right way in who we give access to
all that you know that date I mean
because logging on access to databases
from repository how to do that it's just
we I don't think we have a consensus on
what we should be giving out who should
be really be having access to it it's
not to be a technical problem hope this
part be okay go for it
right but to me that's working out the
policy right because everything you're
kind of talking about you're trying to
enable some use case do we have
consensus on all the use cases you know
we want and how would we enable them
right so maybe you can give a specific
example of protocol we've worked here a
couple years ago actually has seen small
Jake who's also sitting there was one of
the collaborators in this effort so we
essentially looked at ways to prevent
diseases of the future or essentially
informing people who would catch say
hepatitis by eating some food in in some
some restaurant so what we did is we
created an environment with people who
are centers that's track center where
you're going and that would leave
encrypted marks essentially encrypted
breadcrumbs whatever you've done them
with wherever you've been and now these
breadcrumbs will be encrypted in a
fashion that if there was an outbreak a
legitimate outbreak of some illness and
you crossed a path with one of these
people then you could get notified by by
this effort but by the system so for
example you a that the same restaurant
as several people got an illness often
we utilized a variety of cryptographic
mechanisms to implement this such a
secret cheering so you would have we had
the property for example if at least
five people got ill and they ate at the
same restaurant on the same day then my
breadcrumb can be decrypted and then i
could be notified so this is an example
of a specific protocol and i can refer
you to the paper ultimately so let's go
to question number five and then number
six and we will nearly end at number six
go for it
since 2008 my question is what
responsibility are these
yeah I've heard of size
craigslist
a couple sites have lots of trouble
also my boss wants told about the psycho
please Rob be calm it's basically
collecting data from Twitter and the
ones who take that may I get kind of
quick response what is it responsibility
as little as they can get away with with
now now get it without getting sued that
mean to be perfectly blunt I mean it's a
trade off with regulatory things to
where they think the hits going to be on
their reputation you know the twitter
thing is kind of funny because right
this week Library of Congress said
everything that's public we're going to
try to archive so you know kind of in
the coming weeks when we see how that
discussion goes it seems to me that
there's there some companies that really
are Teflon right they get away with this
stuff all the time Facebook regularly
makes you know does odd things with
privacy people still come back because
everyone kind of loves it it would seem
like other companies survive less from
it but i think the the positive thing is
we're seeing more convictions of folks
exfiltrating data for organizations you
know there's real jail time happening
and so there are almost is some
consciousness that it's a penalty it's
perhaps a more severe white-collar crime
here these things then there's also
cases like the YouTube Google case where
they were five Google executives got
arrested in Italy because they had
failed to take down some content now
they took it down when they were
notified but by Google doesn't routinely
go and look at every video that that is
uploaded and the Italian Court said
doesn't matter you're guilty and I think
a lot of the response and the privacy
community has been that well on the one
hand you know it protecting privacy and
not having this stuff up is a good thing
but on the other hand it's it's not
really realistic to demand of all all
companies like Google and YouTube that
they check every bit of content up there
so there's kind of a dilemma there well
legalize too and this this is kind of a
personal story but I got a letter the
other week from a web retailer saying
that their payment systems had been
compromised and it's possible that my
credit card date I got you know
inadvertently downloaded I was impressed
with the letter not only because they
just completely came out with it but
also they in the
top corner there was a card that I could
use to get in contact with an identity
theft prevention or protection agency
where they will take my case and then
work it you know and that was offered
free of charge for the next year so at
any time if my identity is stolen I can
work with these guys to help and and
they weren't I don't even have to prove
that it came from this particular
incident it could have been from
anything so and but that would have
never happened at that hole I forget
what the first case was it was out in
California where payment processor was
compromised and it came out after the
fact and then they were forced by some
law to notify everybody that that
happened I think that kind of that legal
precedent that law kind of set the stage
for for that deterrent to start to
working for companies to probably store
less credit card data for less time or
take better care of it while they do
have it actually mad how do you know
this letter was legitimate you're right
you're right I don't number six
openness transparency privacy
is this
yeah i mean that's you know to anecdotal
things right that's what whale fishing
is all about that's how I I know what
that is and kind of second we had an
allegedly Sarah Palin's email account
get hacked it's it's those those backup
questions not your password but those
personal questions that honestly no one
should answer truthfully because we can
keep garter most of that you know often
that and you're right i mean it's so
that of an antiquary it's really a trade
on you're exactly right and so we should
rely on mechanisms that you when we post
that you know up there we should infer
and trust from let me make one comment
i'm told that we are out of time but i
think i want to make one comment just to
make you aware so let's assume that we
could fix the security and privacy issue
the way we want within the US even if we
did that we would have not done much
because the internet is pretty much
global in unless we harmonize laws both
on the security side and the privacy
side internationally there is not much
progress we are going to make and i
think as we leave this panel while we
are more informed about issues that
relate to security and privacy at least
within this country let's not forget
that whenever we get a chance we have to
think about harmonizing the laws across
states across countries on an
international basis so with that please
join me in giving my panel a big hand
you